thomas bonjour vous êtes donc sur place
quelles sont les revendications
précisément de la profession alors ces
revendications elles s'articulent
notamment autour de trois axes d'abord
une meilleure rémunération une
reconnaissance de la profession de
sage-femme et de meilleures conditions
de travail c'est pour toutes ces
revendications que ces sages femmes se
sont rassemblées vous le voyez derrière
moi elles sont environ une centaine et
ça continue à arriver il faut noter que
beaucoup de sages-femmes sont venus de
différentes villes en france que ce soit
de bretagne de tourcoing ou encore de
clermont ferrand spécialement pour cette
journée d'action cette journée dite sans
sage-femme pour à l'occasion de la
journée internationale des sages-femmes
il s'agit de la cinquième mobilisation
de l'année pour cette profession qui
demande des réponses parce qu'elles se
sont oubliés oubliés notamment pendant
la crise sanitaire où elles n'ont pas
été suffisamment doté en termes de
masques en termes de tests pcr elles
n'ont pas non plus été incluse dans la
campagne de vaccination et plus
généralement ce sont des conditions de
travail qui se détériore d'année en
année on a interrogé une sage femme
originaire de saint-brieuc qui travaille
à l'hôpital de saint-brieuc ge propose
de l'écouter au micro de bâtisses bosse
là on a de plus en plus de
responsabilités et il me semble qu'on
ait de moins en moins reconnu alors que
quand j'étais jeune sage femme en talent
de naissance par exemple les achats
mettez les patronnes et on nous
considérait à notre juste place
ornaisons parisienne il ya un gros
problème de recrutement des sages-femmes
contenait pas forcément province il ya
des sages femmes qui après leurs années
d'études renonça à faire ce métier parce
que mal payés parce qu'ils méprisent et
parce que des horaires de travail très
difficiles
on n'est pas les seuls dans le monde des
soignants 1
mais voilà on veut est considérée et on
l abri sont parfois qui bien que le juge
qui nous considèrent comme profession
médicale quand il ya un problème
alors dans ce rassemblement il ya des
sages femmes de tout âge parce que les
jeunes aussi sont impactés par ces
conditions de travail qui se détériorent
la formation notamment est compliqué il
ya beaucoup de dents out c'est aussi des
sages-femmes qui renonce dès qu'elle
arrive sur le marché du travail parce
que les salaires ne sont pas à la
hauteur du volume horaire notamment qui
leur ai demandé alors voilà pour cette
mobilisation qui vous l'entendez est
plutôt festive il ya beaucoup de
pancartes très imagé vous pouvez
l'imaginer sur le domaine justement de
la natalité de la maternité alors cette
manifestation va partir de
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur on
se trouve actuellement ce sera aux
alentours de 11h30 beaucoup tam abonnés
pour toutes ces précisions va vous
retrouver dans courant de nos prochaines
éditions